in neo possessed and blood lusting
samurai fight alongside a who's-who
creatures and demons from Japanese
folklore known as yokai ogres move with
the agility of ninjas and Buddhists
ravens can kill you with two
klaustreichs the bosses in particular
can be troublesome and figuring out
their weaknesses takes time and a lot of
lost lives lucky for you we figure them
out so you don't have to if you're still
on the fence about neo you can check out
my review at GameSpot and YouTube if
you're ready let's hunt some yokai this
electrified beasts weakness is its chest
so keep the fight up close and personal
dodge its roles but don't follow nuez
path when you go in for the kill new way
leaves a lightning trail so approach it
from an angle instead
it's most predictable move is its
overhead lightning attack which always
features four strikes like other enemies
with aggressive lunges and four dashes
this pipe smoker exposes itself to
attack after its spear stem so when it
winds up be ready to sidestep you'll
know you've reached the second phase
when it begins to throw sticky bombs
take these out of the equation by
staying close to the giant toad
preferably behind it the first thing you
should do in this fight is eliminate the
poison in the air look for two giant
black crumpets shaped mounds on the
ground and destroy them to remove the
poison the trick to this fight isn't
capitalizing on the area's large space
if you're quick enough you can pull off
aerial stabs if you're on a platform
while the boss is below you
the most reliable approach is to chip
away at its health by focusing on the
centipedes many segments as you get a
few hits in ilk rain its head 180
degrees so retreat until there's another
opening to attack more segments if you
prolong the fight you can activate your
living weapon at least twice
of the many human bosses in neo this is
one of the more challenging ones by now
you'll have defended yourself against
your share of spearmen
so many of chimas moves should be
familiar to you he's tougher when he
activates his living weapon but like all
living weapons it's only available for a
limited time
keep your distance while you wait for
Shima to go back to normal if you want
to take him on while his living weapon
is active wait for him to execute his
aerial stab which leaves him open to
attack for a second or two
this skeleton is one of the very few
giant bosses of Nia and unsurprisingly
you need to run a lot to attack its
vulnerable parts the most dangerous area
is the bottom of the pit which is also
where you'll be spending most of your
time focus on the feet while being
mindful of the skeleton stomps and jumps
while dodging don't stray too far from
its feet if you're along the outside
edge you're exposing yourself to its
sweeping tail attack with enough hits
the skeleton will fall exposing its head
to a direct attack
if you paid attention to the warnings of
the corpses in the caverns leading up to
this boss then you know that this bat
lady is a literal life sucker her
vampiric ability is doubly troubling
since the hell that you lose replenishes
hers
to avoid this watch for her two-handed
lunges which is easy to spot since it's
one of her slower moves her paralysis
attacks are particularly frustrating so
be sure to scour the caverns and caves
for more weapons and gear with anti
paralysis attributes when she takes to
the air run under and pass her to avoid
her ranged attacks strike when she dives
back to the ground since she'll be
exposed for a couple seconds before you
take on this giant blob of a boss take
your time exploring the watery ruins of
this map the key is to look for and
light three bonfires for each one that
you light a larger fire box is lint
during the boss fight this is very
useful since Umi BOSU is weak against
fire arm yourself with weapons and gear
with fire affinity while you're at it
whatever you do don't stand directly in
front of it Bumi BOSU fires an energy
beam that can kill you instantly
stay close to this yokai to take her
klaustreichs
out of the equation stamina management
is key since you need to run for cover
to avoid the wide area of effect of her
overhead attacks if you've stopped up on
stamina enhancing items the ogre assist
second phase is the time to use them the
flowers that bloom during the stage of
the battle will create key dead zones
your stamina recovery will be severely
limited so pick your spots carefully
when resuming your attacks
[Music]
for some of you this frosty gal will be
neo's hardest boss her most lethal
attack is a stab which is hard to defend
given the subtlety of its warning side
you'll know she's about to attempt a
stab when her staff disappears this is
not to be confused with her staff throat
which like her other range attacks is
easy to avoid with side steps it's good
practice to keep your distance for most
of the fight and rely on your long
distance attacks for more neo guides and
my review check out GameSpot and make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]
you
[Music]